yesterday was something of a wonderful
anniversary 10 years ago today
Massachusetts became the first state to
legalize same-sex marriage yes yes 10
year anniversary of gay marriage and
that sound you hear is a lesbian
somewhere in Northampton just figuring
out why her partner was in a mood all
day yesterday yeah happy Saturday I
guess Linda sings that's all this seems
to be to you 10 years since
since then we've come even further with
gay marriage it's now legal in 17 states
and Counting but for all the
accomplishments in the political realm
marriage equality still faces some
unusual obstacles Nintendo is a target
of a social media campaign and the
company's upcoming video game called the
Tomodachi life you can make your avatar
do just about anything but what your
avatar cannot do is marry another avatar
of the same sex I mean sure you can use
a civil union cheat code but it's just
not the same if you're interested it's
up up down down be gay be gay start
enough and keep that yourself but in a
happy sign of progress Nintendo made a
historic announcement this week Nintendo
is now apologizing pledging to be more
inclusive in the future and while it
says it's too late to change the game
now it is committed to building virtual
equality into later versions of the game
yes virtual eventual equality that's the
dream now let's see how this news went
down in Nintendo's world this week as
you can see Mario just got the call of
areas he's overjoyed about the news that
this is friendly and they are
I gave not know
young mario peach and Princess Zelda
I called that years ago let's let's
leave that let's give them some privacy
let's give them some privacy shall we oh
that's wonderful Yoshi and told wasting
no time getting married the beauty is
they've now got access to instant
benefits power-ups pensions in the box
that's great you'll love to see
stability in a game like that and well
this is bittersweet Bowser's just
received death benefits after the death
of his longtime partner Donkey Kong so
that's good they had a wonderful
lifetime together
Donkey Kong would have wanted him taken
care of why are you so sad that Donkey
Kong dies multiple times every day would
it make you happier if I restarted the
game is that something ok let's do that
restart the game right now there you go
see let them take their back
enjoying brunch together see happy now
they're brunching are you not had to
change